♪
>>> STRIPPED IT AWAY.
PASS TO JACKSON.
>> THE DEEP PLAY.
HE MIGHT HAVE BEEN BETTER OFF
TAKING IT TO THE HOOP INSTEAD OF
SETTLING FOR THE JUMPER.
>> PASS TO NEWTON, TO THE LEFT
RING.
>> NOT SHY FROM OUTSIDE.
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
SPREADING THE FLOOR AND GETTING
THEM UP.
WELL, THEY'LL BE HAPPY WITH THAT
LOOK EVEN THOUGH IT DIDN'T FALL.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
HE'D TAKE THAT 10 OUT OF 10
TIMES.
HE WON'T MISS MANY OF THOSE.
>> I LOVE HIS SHOT SELECTION
TODAY.
HE SET THE BAR FOR THE REST OF
THE TEAM.
SHOTS ARE JUST FLOWING FOR HIM
RIGHT NOW, HAVING A REALLY
STRONG QUARTER.
>> STOLEN.
>> HE HAS BEEN SO BIG HERE IN
THE FOURTH QUARTER.
5 OF 6 FROM THE FIELD.
>> HERE'S THE LOB TO THE HOOP!
JACKSON TRYING TO BREAK FREE.
SENT AWAY!
>> GOT TO HAVE MORE OF THIS
MOVEMENT.
HE'S HALF HIS SIZE.
NEEDS IT TO TURN BACK SHOTS.
>> THERE'S THE DISH TO JACKSON.
>> SOME PLAYERS MIGHT WEAR DOWN
DOING THIS KIND OF RUN.
HE'S ONLY GETTING STRONGER.
>> DISHES TO JACKSON.
OVER TO THE LEFT WING.
>> AND HERE IN THE FOURTH HE'S
CARRYING THIS TEAM RIGHT NOW.
5 OF 7 FROM THE FIELD.
>> TO THE LEFT WING.
>> WITH THE ROLL HE'S ON THIS
QUARTER, HE'LL KEEP GOING TO
HIM.
GET THAT LEAD EVEN BIGGER.
>> OUT LEFT TO THE WING.
>> WHAT A HUGE BOOST HE'S GIVING
THEM.
4 OF 5 IN THIS FOURTH QUARTER,
HAS COME UP BIG.
>> NOW THE PASS TO NEWTON.
BACK TO JACKSON.
>> AND WITH THE GAME IN THE
BALANCE HERE IN THE FOURTH, HE'S
BEEN UNFLAPPABLE.
6 OF 8 FROM THE FIELD PROVIDING
THEM WITH SOME BIG BUCKETS.
>> JACKSON TRYING TO BREAK FREE.
>> HOW ABOUT THESE BIG SHOTS FOR
HIM IN THE FOURTH.
HE'S BEEN LOCKED AND LOADED
OFFENSIVELY.
>> TO THE PAINT.
ANOTHER STEAL.
AND THAT GOES OUT OF BOUNDS.
AND THEY RETAIN POSSESSION.
♪